si vous avez envie de faire du sport
collectif et bien les mercredis sportifs
sont faits pour eux il s'agit d'une
opération organisée par le département
du haut rhin
elle vise à faire découvrir aux plus
jeunes des sports d'équipé
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les jeunes
de côtoyer des sportifs de haut niveau
nora voir yoann s'est rendu sur place ce
mercredi à kingersheim à la découverte
du volley ball avec l' as ptt mulhouse
regarder mes shows foie en commun
après on fait différents ateliers où
c'est les joueuses qui entraîne les
enfants et on termine sur un tournoi
un goûter distribution de posters
signatures d'autographes et voilà quand
on est des joueuses professionnelles
quand on quand on joue au plus haut
niveau
enfin doit être un exemple et on doit
être capable de transmettre aux plus
jeunes notre passion et leur donner
envie les faire rêver de devenir joueuse
professionnelle elle y a des enfants qui
sont tout petits voilà on l'a on voit
que ça va de 2 4 à 15 ans donc forcément
il va falloir adapter les contenus par
rapport aux différentes catégories d'âge
après je pense que quand les jeunes de
ressort de cet après midi avec les yeux
qui brillent et l'envi de voile à l ont
côtoyé peut-être la ville de lors de la
présentation des joueuses 20 il
connaissait tous les noms et les prénoms
de chacune donc à la pompe pour ces
enfants là c'est à mon avis une après
midi qui restera inoubliable
[Applaudissements]